i want to let you know next week i'll be
back on a regular solo episode
and i'm looking forward to that
um
so i will see you then we could just do
a little bit of mono imano
or monoi womano as well will include
everybody
this week february 2nd i'm in
jacksonville
florida
and february 3rd i'm in st petersburg
florida america
february 5th i'll be in orlando
that's this week so you can grab those
tickets theovan.com tour
i'm also in tampa and then i'll be in
lafayette
indiana that's sold
2 out
i'll be in rockford
illinois it's february 25th february 26
in chicago
at the chicago theater
very excited
and yeah rockford illinois home of the
rockford peaches a feminine baseball
group
that did it all almost one at all i
think they want it
theovan.com
tour t-o-u-r for tickets don't get
tickets from any third-party sites
only go through theovon.com
tour if you're paying a ridiculous
amount of money for a ticket it's
probably because
you it's some aftermarket site some
peddler grifter
we also have the new i'm upstairs
collection
available in hoodies long sleeves and
tees i wore my black hoodie yesterday
that says it
and the be good to yourself collection
as well always available uh go to
theovonstore.com thank you guys so much
for your support uh coming to see the
shows and any merchandise or anything i
love you
today's episode is being taped at howie
mandel's studio
out here in um
uh california
so we're taping it here and we're
grateful to howie mandel
for that thank you
today's guest
is uh is a friend of mine
he's a deer man
and i don't mean he's a hunter or
anything i mean he's just a dear man
and he is um he's one half of the
podcasting duo hey babe that he hosts
with sal volcano
and he is a full
both halves of his solo podcast chris c
chaos
uh that you can check out
um he is currently
touring in cities on his chrissy
theater's everywhere tour the cete tour
tickets are available at chris d comedy
he and i have a long history of
podcasting together this one's right in
time for valentine's day man
we're going to talk about love
um
and i'm grateful that he's here uh my
friend mr chris de stefano
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
so you know but chrissy d you know what
i mean
your [ __ ] chrissy d
you know what i mean like look at that
you're not wearing bracelets like that
unless you're doing something unless you
know what i mean what is that is that
all bloomingdale's where'd you where'd
you get it got that amazon but it you
know what i mean wow yeah and what
carrot is that is that 30
might be 30.
that's a good amount yes sir and i got a
chain
oh wow yeah i got to chain 10. cuban
link raise you know what i mean i'm just
saying like that's
you know you're adding shows at a funny
bone with that yeah yeah oh look
and you're married still to your wife
right yes well we're not married but we
have children so we're married in the
eyes of god
and did you know when you were gonna be
in love like did you not like when you
take me to it for real and be honest
with me because i've been thinking a lot
about love and like
how do i get you know being just jumping
in and being like i'm in love you know
and like like i don't have a girlfriend
anything right now but it's like
really yeah but i've been thinking about
it it's tough to be single with a jacket
like that because you're
i'm soaked thanks man you look good in
it man i think it's one of one of those
like andre agassi collection things no
it's [ __ ] it's money in the bank
jacket i just i really like the jacket
thanks i actually saw a man with it who
did skydiving is the first time that i
ever saw it
yeah it looks like something like
whitney houston would wear but i love
whitney houston really yes
whitney houston is my number one pho i
was watching the whitney houston
documentary on the plane coming out here
fully crying in delta economy
i've told you bro adam chose at funny
bones yeah so that's good dude if you
what uh
do you um what are we talking about you
were asking me about love and yeah you
want to find you know did you know okay
i'm gonna be 100 honest with you yeah
all right
this is for real in 2014 when i met okay
hold on what was the climate of the
world in 2014 2014 people were kind of
getting along pretty well we were
getting along we had uh obama's
president you know um there were real no
problems on the horizon you know china
was starting to act up a little bit
you're starting to hear you know like
china was always like uh watch them a
little bit but we really didn't have the
problems we have
right now you know we were two years
away from being saved by trump and now
we're back in the [ __ ] but yeah so
it was kind of like a little bit of a
glory days but i was single i had been
single for six months
um had you been dating kind of
vigorously had you been doing sex a lot
again just being completely 100
vulnerable and honest from the time uh
uh from from from uh january of 2014
okay until august of 2014 yes
i i contracted chlamydia so many times
that my primary care doctor gave me my
own prescription of azithromycin which
is what cures chlamydia almost like a
male birth control he's like any time
you it just hurts a little bit to pee
just take this he said because i can't
stop you he said and it's amazing you
don't have herpes aids or syphilis but
you got chlamydia like i've never gotten
covered once
but i get chlamydia like chlamydia is
like you know what i mean yeah you were
yeah you were and so he was scoring
chlamydia yes the john miranda yeah he
would i would pee in a company would go
like that like was a hot potato because
my urine was 100 degrees
so
so yeah
yeah
this thing's it looks a little bullier
basically yeah that's when it's bad boy
i remember one time when you got that
chicken noodle piss yeah
chicken noodle pizza committee on the
side so i i remember one time i gave him
a cup of my urine and i said is it bad
and he goes
he goes feel it what do you think and i
was like it's it's a little warm he goes
yeah it's not just be like that wow i
was like yeah he went he went
so okay so so
get to august 27
so so let me tell you something yeah
listen at that time you know i i i was i
was you know there was a lot of
beautiful women i was recently single i
i you know
i was out there in the world with comedy
and i was i was i was hooking up with
with beautiful women and and having a
good time i had a beautiful apartment in
long island city new york out of view of
the city i was really really like being
free and single for the first time in my
life were you on the apps were you just
meeting women at shows just meeting
women at shows on instagram i never did
any of those apps not never once i like
it um um i did
native american basically of dating i
was native american i was hunting
buffalo and some of them were buffalo
but i don't discriminate you know what i
mean so you got some gazelles on
buffaloes it depends oh yeah dude i've
been with some yeah wounded antelope you
know what i'm saying 100 i had sex with
a woman who was on dialysis
you know oh wow is that good for them
that's good well it it she wouldn't
she'd be dead without it she was in her
mid-40s on dialysis she was actually a
friend of my father's and they met at
dialysis and i wound up having sex with
her it wasn't a proud moment but i did
um and because i was in i was just in
that in that time in 2014 i was just
very i was finding women that felt empty
like me that were you know having sex
enough
i don't [ __ ] anybody out of like an
urgent care or nothing you won't do it
no
yeah i don't do it man my sister works
at him i've seen yeah some behind the
scenes i'm not doing that [ __ ] yeah no i
guess somebody's rolling out of her
urgent care i'm not [ __ ] you're not
gonna i know having sex with a woman on
dialysis was i don't want to say it was
a low point but you know i mean it was
uh it was dangerous because you know she
was had blurred vision and [ __ ] and i
was like you know i don't even know if
she's uh
yeah so so so august 2014 this seriously
take me there it's a 2004 i'm sorry july
of 2014 it was july 6th okay my boy pat
finnegan patty fly ball shout out uh he
just fell down the stairs yesterday and
had a laceration on his chin he tripped
over his dog leash um so shout out him
he said yeah
lost consciousness yeah yeah um
so he we went to a place uh in brooklyn
it was called place to beach in coney
island brooklyn okay and would you say
in volleyball they're having sand
volleyball um and it was this is a place
in brooklyn where this isn't like
gentrified woke brooklyn this was like
where native new yorkers are going okay
you know you have the puerto ricans and
the italians going out there it's coney
island like yeah coney island is like
it's not gentrified man that's real new
york city like you gotta be from new
york to even know where these spots are
at that was one of those spots i wasn't
looking for anything i wasn't looking
for i i was just i was out there maybe
going why did you go that day because
pat finnegan had told me he's like yo my
sister's there with her friends oh yeah
so let's go meet my sister's friends
because it's just a beautiful girl and
we were like okay yeah we'll go have fun
drink i had a show
at the creek in the cave r.i.p the creek
in the cave it was in queens new york at
the time i was supposed to have a show
at the creek in the cave at eight
o'clock i said let's go to that place at
five yeah we'll do it we'll have a
couple of drinks i was drinking
strawberry vodka i should get strawberry
vodkas and i said let's get drunk we'll
drive my my jeep grand cherokee out
there and then you know we'll take the
bus to the creek if if we can't drive i
got a grand cherokee see similarities
so and we both got 80s jackets on yeah
it's nice dude and i got and i got that
bracelet i don't have it so so
i'm i'm um we're in there and again not
looking for anything and again i was at
the point you know a lot of beautiful
women were you feeling hopeful
i was feeling
i was feeling i remember i was feeling
good i felt i was wearing the right
shorts and the right shirt that i felt
like i was in better shape than i
actually was i felt tight even though i
probably had eaten pizza and carbs but i
felt tight and good yeah i love that
when your shirt does that for you cause
you know like right now i don't feel
good i feel fat i feel bloated i'm just
trying to cover it up because i don't
feel good man because i had a muffin
this morning but yeah so i had a two
muffins this morning actually and a
jalapeno cheese bagel and i had cold
oatmeal on the plane what can you do i'm
chrissy carbs wow yeah i went in i
probably had 4 000 calories it's barely
3 o'clock damn dude you know barely it's
not even february yet i know dude so i i
i eat like my drug is i eat too much and
uh you know but what can i do so you're
on strawberry vodkas you have a nice fit
on you're there
and do you are y'all doing activities
what are you doing no so we're in the
bar literally just listening to you know
the house music uh uh you know trying to
talk to girls dancing
just being stupid and i i go to take a a
piss they had a porta potty there
yeah so i go to take a piss i like a
port-a-potty dude because it's almost
like you feel brave when you even go
piss you're like you're not like
magellan but you're like i'm going to
try you know what i'm saying i'm doing
something different and it was and and
the port-au-pon is the only time in my
life before kova that anytime i use a
porta-potty i would look to wash my
hands or purell because 100 of the time
even if i dutied i would never wash my
hands before covered i was like i don't
need to wash my hands unless i was in a
porta potty
so with the port-a-potty the hard part
is getting the door open you almost
gotta kick it with your foot and let it
bounce a little and then catch it with
your foot yeah you got to do something
you got to act like you don't have even
have hands like you just got nubs yeah
so
so i
i'm there
i come out i come out i met a you know i
met a guy i i used to be a physical
therapist i i had a patient i should say
that was just a torso let's don't say a
is it called a patient if you're
physically yes no they would call us
patients and we technically have
doctorate degrees i mean i have a
doctor's degree i would never call
myself doctor some of my you know
classmates did and yeah that's [ __ ]
but they were called patients and i met
he was a torso just a toy no arms no
legs
did you speak at churches no no no no i
think he's no longer with us but he was
just a full torso oh wow and it was
crazy to see but he would maneuver like
he would get [ __ ] done just rolling
around
you know what during him ernie
that's crazy and does he have a spine or
not or just like a rib cage no he had a
full head spine everything but he was
just just think about like a mannequin
okay with no arms no legs just think
about hold on hold on you're talking so
fast it's hard for me to know sorry well
think about it sorry i'm sorry so
thinking about a mannequin all right and
what else
no arms no legs all right head brain
spine okay
tattoo on his rib cage
oh wow yeah
didn't see that coming yep and he was
having um
he was having i think it was shoulder
issues
uh because uh easily neck neck shoulder
because that's all you got left it's
just his neck yeah and he was born that
way by the way he wasn't in an accident
and this is true i'm i'm you know i
could probably prove it to you he was
also a hermaphrodite oh wow so so he was
and he was blind in one eye this is i
i'm not making any of this up i can't
say his name because that's against
hipaa yeah you know but but he he is the
patient if anyone who worked with me at
nyu in uh you know summer spring or
whatever it was of 2010
you know exactly who i'm talking about
damn yeah well that's probably not a lot
of it and that's you know
i think you got big i mean my
my people are working with big fans of
yours absolutely
so so so with that being said i um i i i
see you're there i'm there
it's july 6th of 2014. okay
i see
who's going to eventually become my the
mother of my two beautiful children wow
and so when i saw her dude never forget
i saw i was drinking strawberry vodka
having fun i was probably you know on an
app looking for domino's pizza i'm
always anytime i drink even though new
york city has the best italian food
every time i drink i always want pizza
hut and dominoes i think it's just pain
it's just a cycle of pain it's like i
want to look in the mirror and be like
you [ __ ] suck you eat that domino's
[ __ ] oh yeah something like that like
bdsm yeah it's like like a suicidal
thing you know like italian bdsm yes yes
so i say i see her i see her and she's
like dancing and it was one of those
things where it was like almost like in
a movie where i was like like
truthfully i was like my heart like
stopped like i was like like it's the
only time i ever felt that in my life
wow where i looked at her and i was like
oh my god like like the beauty was like
like floored and again like i said i was
i i said everything before i had you
know we're talking to beautiful women
and ben so she was beautiful like you
know there were other girls but there
was something different about her and i
said to my boy patty patty fly balls who
whenever he was chewing on a straw and i
said to him i do that yeah i said to him
i said um i said dude look at how
beautiful that woman is and she he was
like i know she's amazing and i was like
he he agreed he agreed and i was like i
was that's nice
i said that i said
i said that literally is the hottest
girl i've ever seen in my life i was
like i can't even think right now and he
was like oh and he was like bro relax
what'd you do then you left no so he
goes he goes dude yeah she's a smoking
hot puerto rican chick like i get it
like
and i said i gotta go up and talk to her
i said i literally was like inside of me
i was like if i do not talk to her like
this is gonna bother me for the rest of
my [ __ ] life like i'm never gonna
forget this woman so i go up to her and
i say listen i said i you know i saw you
from across was the music loud was it
hard to get her attention
that part i don't remember because i was
enamored because you know what's amazing
about her she was so beautiful and
obviously is so beautiful but the thing
is what i focus on is she has a chipped
tooth so i was looking at her chipped
tooth because i was like wow
you know you're like from afar like you
don't notice you have a chipped tooth
but then when i get closer it's almost
like the chip tooth it even made it more
beautiful because it's like it's unique
it's almost like a like a hot chick with
a scar you know what i mean like i was
like i like this this is yeah it's
almost like you got to buy a vowel or
something yeah like one of the most
beautiful women i've ever met besides
her has no pinkies and i was like and
she's a smoke show but she's got no
pinkies and she hides them but she's you
don't meet people that don't have
pinkies yeah and she doesn't have them
but she's gorgeous wow she's almost like
a sloth almost yes she's dude i'll tell
you this first girl i ever kissed had a
chipped tooth yep
yep and they made us kiss we were in
love man i don't know if we were in love
but we live near each other
well sometimes that's all it takes
that's what being in love was and being
married was in ancient times you just
knew the people in your village that's
why this whole concept of a soulmate you
there's nine billion people in this
world and we're all connected through
mark zuckerberg the god yeah so it's
like you this whole idea of a soulmate
and a one and only that's that's ancient
tribe [ __ ] this is not new world
thinking because new we're all connected
man you just you knew about 15 people
right back in the day right so you know
what i mean so
with her with jasmine
i walked up to her and i said i said i
it's it's i can't stop
like looking at you guys wow i said do
you have a boyfriend you're a full
psychopath with the first time i can't
stop looking
[Laughter]
you should have had somebody write it on
your back with a marker and just pull
your shirt up yeah i went full psycho
because i was just so and i just love
brother that's what i'm telling you
that's love yeah and i said to her i
said is there any way i could just buy
you a drink and she said you could but
my boyfriend is here so then i was like
whoa cause i got a rule man if you got a
boyfriend i don't mess with that right
husband like i don't i think that's bad
karma i would never want that i don't
mess with that like oh there's plenty of
fish in the sea but something about her
i was like
i almost feel like it doesn't matter
like i don't care that you know like i
almost have to be like i don't care at
all that you have a boyfriend
yeah i have to take a chance even if
this guy kills me because i'm sure based
off what you look like you probably have
like some guido like convict
murderer brooklyn italian boyfriend
which i was right volleyball playing too
yup
uh my stepdad found out that some lady
was getting married that he used to have
a huge crush on
and he went over he was at a bar or
something that night he found out she's
got engaged and he drove over to the
house
and went up on her porch like in the
middle of the night
and said look i got all these feelings
for you and blah blah blah and she
didn't care right and while he was up
there somebody burned his car
everybody's
literally his car is burning which is a
horrible look if you're trying to tell
somebody like that you're the guy for
them you know it's just like
and then you come back with a bicycle
yeah no way dude you're not that guy
your car set on fire yeah i don't know
what happened i i either left a
cigarette in the dash or something that
happened you know
online shopping isn't slowing down
anytime soon that's right it's here to
stay
fortunately or unfortunately i kind of
miss the old days but
the old days are just that
is your business
ready to keep up the pace with new uh
you know with the updated online
shopping
well ship station can help
you'll never worry about shipping again
that's
you don't want to be worrying about
shipping you're already worrying about
making a good product
make the switch to a solution that
handles all your shipping needs
ship station
keep track of orders
on your phone from any sales channel
manage every order amazon ebay etsy or
your own website if you're selling uh
knuckle covers
lonnie's knuckle covers dot com or
something and you gotta get a batch of
uh
of uh k covers out to somebody
they'll help
ship station makes shipping easy
98 of companies that use shipstation for
a year
keep using it for as long as they're in
business
use my offer code theo to get a 60 day
free trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in t-h-e-o
ship station make ship happen
you know it's tough to keep things fresh
you know especially uh to keep your body
fresh dang that's hard
get that fresh body
you show up you look like you've been in
the crisper drawer in your refrigerator
people say damn boy
you're looking real lettucy you looking
real uh
real perfectly uh
kempt fitness
will keep you fresh
and who can do it i'll tell you who can
do with his peloton they're helping out
they've got a lot of fresh ideas over
there they got
boxing now
they've got new music selections they've
got more daily workout variety that's
right peloton is not just the peloton
bike and peloton bike plus
though those are great they got new
classes now new music
new ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating
they have boxing
even if you've never boxed
you don't fight if you never fought
anybody after school if you ever never
fought your wife or stepmother or
husband
these classes will have you working up a
sweat
working on the fundamentals of the form
and the footwork
new artists music selection collabs
they've got it from hip hop to rock and
roll
to edm
that's right peloton is a workout for
every day and every schedule all types
check them out bike workouts yoga
meditation dance cardio and more go to
one peloton dot com that's o n e
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
so so
you know she says i got a boyfriend and
i said i can't i won't be deterred not
on this one
so i said you know what i'm i'm just
gonna have to stick around and fight
this out and and for like an hour
i would you know kept drinking and i was
just like you know what man like i gotta
and i know she was talking to the
bartender and so the bartender was
turned out to be one of her close
friends still is one of her close
friends and so i said to the bartender i
said what what is it gonna what is it
going to take for me what is it going to
take for me to get this your friend to
like look at me and notice me i was like
does she really have a boyfriend and she
was like i can't answer that and i was
like oh so they're playing history she
does not have a boyfriend what's it
called a misdirect
no i think it's called like a um turn of
events a turn of events
so
she says i i i can't i i can't answer
that i said well what's it gonna take
and she was like she's she's she loves
dancing she's like and she's puerto
rican like you gotta come up with some
type of yeah they love dancing like you
got to dance like do you know how to do
bachata and i said
i'm going to try yeah so i googled
bachata and i told them i told kashichat
the music you know she's a bartender i
said let me go let me let me look at
some [ __ ] let me a couple of youtube
some stuff and so i said and my boy was
like yo dude remember that scene and
along came polly when ben stiller
started dancing spanish
and that's how he got
his woman so we watched that scene and i
played that song from that movie no yes
so i played that song and i'm like i'm
just going to come up to her and dance
with her and then oh my god this is
freaking getting good yeah dude so she
said so she so so the bartender was like
i'm going to play that song for you and
you come up with those dance moves no
were you scared yeah for all this
madness you could go outside and warm up
or do you just warm up right i was
drinking so i was like having fun with
it you know i was like whatever dude
this is gonna be great yeah and you got
nothing to lose because you're sitting
there with a drinking with an irish man
yeah dude a couple of irish men actually
yeah so i start so they play that song
nothing's further from them being
happily married and sitting somewhere
with two irish dudes drinking right dude
that is the complete opposite of it yeah
so so oh dude and two irish men and with
uh listening to the mets games with the
headphones
you know like they were watching the
mets like they were trying to get the
met score yeah and and and so i just did
that i did that dance played that song
she kind of giggled and she goes and she
goes that was a nice attempt she goes
that was a nice attempt and she goes how
about this i'll tell you my name so she
tells me her name and i was like okay
and she goes and then what i almost it
almost was like it was a setup but i
swear to god it wasn't i had been on a
show on mtv called guy code and girl
code which is relatively still popular
yeah um
the other carly and andrew schultz and
all those guys
guys and girls so so i um i i
uh
somebody came up to me and wanted a
picture with me from that show and then
she was like why do they want a picture
with you and i was like oh i'm on a show
on on it's on mtv and she was like how
old are you i was like 30. and she was
like you still aren't watching mtv and i
was like no i'm not watching it i'm just
on the show yeah yeah that's just uh
that's just that's fine man you're not a
bad guy that's just a business choice i
was like i was like you know i needed i
i'm just i'm working yeah i'm working
she said that the puerto ricans yeah she
said that to me she was like what do you
want right and that so i said um they
trust a lot of television puerto ricans
are more
they're more
real life yes yeah like if i was working
at a gas station or something like that
she'd be more like this is my kind of
guy right but so she was like okay and
then she said um she said what's the
show and i told and she goes all right
maybe i'll look it up one day and i was
like okay
that could take forever dude she's so
vague doesn't she know we only have a
lifetime i know dude so then she goes so
then she goes um
she was like [ __ ] with me so she goes
um she goes all right she goes along
with this hold on she goes i'm leaving
she goes i gotta i gotta get home she
goes i gotta get home to my son oh so
that was so when she said that dropped
the s bomb she dropped the s-bomb so in
my heart
my heart yeah i gotta get it home to my
chlamydia yeah i said i said
if you get i said because already then i
said okay i said well the first thing i
said i said is that you have a son with
your boyfriend she goes no and i said is
she so is the is the son's father around
us or does he is he deceased and she was
like why would you want him to be
deceased i was like i don't i was just i
was just hoping that he was so i could
step in and be a step dad like i just
said that immediately and she was like
you're like crazy and i was like yeah
and she was like
and she was like he's still in the
picture i was like okay so but when she
said that to me i already felt inferior
to him so i said to myself in my heart
and head at that moment i said the first
time i have sex with this woman i'm not
pulling out i need to get her pregnant
too to even the playing field that's how
nuts i was you went full puerto rican
and that's eventually what i did fyi no
way yeah
i met her i met her i met her in august
of 2014. we conceived uh
july of 2014 my daughter delilah was
conceived in august i have a six and a
half two fourteen yeah dude wow my
daughter was born in may of 2015. wow so
so so you purposely impregnated her 1
wow yeah because i felt so inferior to
this guy i didn't even know and i was
like this is the woman of my dreams i'm
going to play hardball i need this he's
got one on the board i'm gonna get one
of them i said yeah and that now i got
two on the board now i got a second kid
so now i'm like two to one [ __ ]
so it's psychotic that's how i live my
life yeah so so i i gotta like this yeah
dude i went all in because everyone was
like you're crazy and i was like i feel
like i'm in an uberx with no breaks yeah
dude i was like yeah maybe i am yeah so
then finally i'll never forget i was at
minnesota at target field i was at the
mlb all-star game okay watching the game
derek jeter's final mlb austin i'm a
huge aggies fan oh yeah i get a message
from
an instagram message from an account i
wasn't sure of and it was just a dog
laying on the floor like this just a it
looked like a dead dog so i was like
this is weird yeah this is wild and then
it said
it said this is me giving in she said
this is me giving in wow and she goes
and she gave me uh
her phone number besides the last digit
um she goes gabe so she was really i
mean making me like movie memento or
whatever yes she gave me the last digit
so i went through
all the digits i went through all of
them and i just texted this number and i
just kept trying that digit and until
yeah and most of them were like who is
this some of the other languages
somebody sent me back chinese symbols
and then finally yeah so i was like
could that be her
i was like jazz first one
yeah so then finally i got the digit the
last digit was actually a zero i started
at one like an idiot and then so zero
just started with zero and nailed it on
the first try so i finally got her
and she said look she she broke down she
was like i have a son i'm not looking
for anything serious but you know she
goes you seem like a funny guy she was
like i looked up your stuff it's pretty
funny she was like i was the the guy
that i was with she was like it was it
was a casual stupid thing she was like
if you want to take me out i'm you know
i have to make arrangements for my son
i'm free
you know next saturday now is there a
lot of pressure because if somebody says
they got a son and then because you're
almost like if you take somebody out
that has a son yeah you got to have a
little bit more of a plan or like be
real serious yeah well he was three at
the time and when i opened the door when
she opened the door for me you can hear
him no he showed up in his karate outfit
he had a karate outfit on with his
orange belt with a headband and he was
holding hatred and why would he have
already be dressed like he's saying he
was holding a monster apple juice just
looking at me and why was he dressed
like that because i think he just wanted
to let him know like let let me know
that he knows karate if i mess with his
mom [ __ ] that's crazy yeah yeah isn't
that crazy it's crazy dude and i've i've
since you know he's my stepson now he
lives with me so he so he's you know
jasmine has since told me like yeah he
he put that on when i told him mommy's
gonna go out with a friend and she he
was like is that is a guy and he when
she said yes then he put it on every
time he smells apples he just breaks a
board in the living room yeah and he no
he still ice grills the [ __ ] out of me
every time i give him his breakfast and
stuff
he's still like dude never forget you
ain't my dad so you took her out where'd
you take her so that's what happened so
i took her out
because this is good for me man because
i want to be in love you know
so
i want to
know how what do i do to get there
so what happened was is i took her i
took her to uh at that time i was
performing at a place called mcguire's
comedy club at the end of long island
that's the saturday i said listen if you
would you like to come to a comedy show
i picked up i had a toyota corolla but
it was a nice one but it was a nice one
dude it was like a 2000 have a nice one
it was a 2014 at automatic windows a lot
of them have the roll-ups but i had
automatic windows at the time and locks
right when she's walking up the car do
you do all four windows down it's just
show where they all do it yeah well no i
got out of the car i i rang the bell
like proper gentleman i had a rose for
her that i bought from the chinese man
on the corner yes i had a rose for and
she was like that's sweet and i was like
thanks and then i told her i was like
this isn't my real car
and she was like where's your real car i
was like it's up here i was like we're
going to get my real car like i was
being honest but i was i was like saying
like
this is a
just stay with me because i'm telling
you i'm going places right but i was
like we're in a toyota now but stay with
me i was like there's nobody at this
show but i was like trust me one day i'm
gonna have a gold bracelet and you
really tell her all this i swear to god
i was like and she was like you don't
have to build yourself up she was like i
think it's cool you do comedy i think
it's brave she was like i don't care if
you have a toyota like it's a nice car
like i have a son yeah she was like
whatever yeah she was like i take the
bus to work she was like i have a tattoo
on my tit like this is nice you know so
i said which is this is a butterfly to
and but i love that so so she said um so
so we go out there we go to the show and
uh it was in like a shopping mall oh
yeah nobody knows that's tough it's
tough and that's tough to bring a girl
to a
place that used to be like a radio shack
or whatever they did jiu jitsu during
the day yeah it was bad it was and yeah
it was next to a diner so it was bad so
but i had a pretty decent set for about
15 people in bohemian new york and
suffolk county long island had a pretty
decent set and i said at the end of the
set i said i want you guys i want you
guys to i want to introduce you to my
new girl
and i said i said let's bring up to the
stage miss jasmine
yeah
and she couldn't believe that i did that
and she was in the back like she was
like i'm not going on stage i was like i
was like baby come on stage with me i
was like i was like come over here yeah
come on let's walk into the future yes
and then she walked up the stairs and
and people you know the guy was like
like whistling out or whatever and i was
like who is that black guy
no man it's my crowd no blacks
um yeah it was bohemia long island you
know they can only go to a certain point
on long island oh really yeah they can
get real urban after a certain yeah you
can't do it yeah i'm kidding by the way
i have a lot i have a very cultured
diverse uh fan base it's like a
community same i was just wondering who
would do the whistle i'm trying no
italian guys it was italian yeah italian
guys will whistle she's puerto rican
beautiful girl italian sauce brothers
basically yes the sauce brothers so they
so i gave her a kiss right there on the
lips dude a [ __ ] tail in front of
everyone yeah dude i put the pressure on
it'd be i'd be in prison for that today
you know i was forced and all that yeah
but that was 2014 there were no rules
back then you know what i mean it was
still the wild wild west you can do
whatever you want to be a me too 100 me
too and maybe it still will come back to
be we'll see if she writes a book
so
so i
i i kissed her and then we got back in
the car and i was like was that crazy
that i did that she was like it was but
she was like i like that you're brave
and i was like wow so then i drove her
back home i drove her back home the ver
and i said and i said listen i said i'm
not gonna come upstairs and she was like
don't even [ __ ] around with me she's
like you're not coming upstairs i was
like i just wanna let you know i'm the
one telling you i'm not that kind of guy
she was like laughing whatever wow then
the second date which was two days later
i took her to a fat joe concert at yeah
yes
and i had known fat joe because we were
co-hosting a show for major league
baseball at the time so he brought me on
stage and brought her backstage
and you know puerto rican connection
so then i was like i sold fagios puerto
rican yeah fat joe's puerto rican
jasmine's puerto rican i was like we're
getting upset i was like we have sex
tonight so damn that first night though
dude i was so nervous and so enamored by
her love and who she was that i couldn't
get my penis up yeah i was just smushing
i've been like that since i was 11. i
couldn't get it up man nothing dude i
was even trying to watch sportscenter
and everything and my dick would not get
hard bro did i remember drawing a hard
dick and showing it to my day yeah dude
yeah and i wouldn't do it i could not
get hard man i was i was doing that i
was watching the like
or whatever i'm saying rorschar yeah i
just couldn't get it up and then she got
embarrassed for herself she was like is
it me like what what's going on
i was like you're almost so beautiful
and i'm so into you that it's having a
counter balance effect and she was like
oh man and i was like this isn't i was
like i'm embarrassed and she was like
i'm embarrassed for you like damn she
was like took somebody
yeah she was old but she said i'm ready
to go she was like i'm drinking no she
was no mean and ready to go ready to
have sex she's like i've been drinking
bacardi all night you just introduced me
to fat joe like i'm ready to go like you
know what i mean like i i want my she
told you that point she said she was
like you just introduced me to fat joe i
i did take her to sabaros but that was
the only thing
i know lady i want to have sex too yeah
but it wouldn't get i know i know i know
and my balls are so long that like when
i when i have like a soft penis like
that like it looked like look like i
have an issue down there and and and i
hadn't shaved my pubes so she was a
little bit like are you ready are you
nuts like your balls are like hanging
past your kneecaps you have a full bush
and you can't get your dick card you
know like like so like i
yeah dude they have long nuts babe you
know what i'm saying baby god but but i
said i got a bible's mistletoe son yo so
i said to her i said can i just cause
she because her son wasn't with her son
i guess was with her his father that
night she had she had had had the night
so i said
you know nothing like i said will you
mind something double dragon conference
probably dude
his son was ready to go
his son was yeah buying an ak-47 so
you're at her place no she's not my
place okay
and she's staying over so now she's
staying over because i said to her i
said can i convince you to stay because
she was like maybe i'll just go whatever
like give me something
to say even if even if i can't get it
right yes because what i knew what i was
counting on was morning wood i said at
least i know for a fact every day since
i've been 12 i wake up with a heart on
normally when i say hemingway i pee it
out i always pee out my morning wood but
i said i'm going to try to have sex with
her
even even if what comes out is just piss
even if i pee in her vagina at least i
got it hard and i could show what's up
yeah because when i'm hard i'm i'm very
decent and i have a like i've been told
one of the best circumcisions like
people have ever seen really not one
mistake do not a scar nothing and if i
get a couple of more yeah it looks like
that uh like charlie brown shirt kind of
a little
the cut you know yeah yeah so that's
what i'm saying so i have a nice so i
was like when i get it up man it's good
you got that eyes out
smooth skin it's a little red at the tip
like it's nice and and really white like
you know i got to redo mine i guess
i want to get my foreskin put back on oh
really my mother still has it
my mother has my foreskin and my first
poop and my first hair for my first
haircut in a box underneath my childhood
bed which has remained untouched you
almost would think i'm dead because she
hasn't changed my room since i left wow
so
i said that's my only hope i can't
believe she did that the morning would
yeah so i woke up she had to wake up and
go to work so she set the alarm at 7am
oh an alarm here's my thing alarm makes
my dick soft really yeah so i have to
like
i just like any like alerts or anything
that's right you know i can't do it if
there's broken glass in the room can't
do it can't do it so i said to her i was
ready to go i said so i said you know
what i'm just gonna have to do this so i
just went down i just went down and i
just went down are you erect yet are you
just hoping it's hard while you're down
no it was fully arrested and then it
started to go down a little bit start to
get nervous while i was going down on
her so i just started dry hump in my bed
i just try to dry hump in my bed to make
sure so while i'm going down i'm drying
up in my bed and she's like are you
having a seizure i'm like no no don't
worry about it like and then i just
popped up and i put it in and you know
it was like you know i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm in and then it felt like you know
responsibility then i was in there and
then i had to pee and i knew every time
when i if i if i masturbate i had sex
with a woman and i hadn't peed and and i
i was i came i would get uh uh some type
of infection not chlamydia like some
type of ut
yeah and i said i know
i'm gonna get a uti but i said you know
what man i said i have to level the
playing field with this guy so i'm gonna
not pull out so i didn't pull out and
you ejaculated yes and i ejaculated but
how do you get the ejaculation past the
urine
it just just will man
wow just pure will i believed it could
happen
so i pushed out and i filled her up with
with p and did you tell her you were
going to
she she was i was like i'm gonna come
i'm gonna come and she was like and then
she was like oh you know like went to
like push me off and i just you know you
stayed on yeah because it felt so good
and she was like what the [ __ ] and i was
like i'm sorry you know whatever and she
was like well let's go get you know the
pill and i said yes of course so we go
get it the same day yeah right away gosh
i had a lot of time left over then if
she had to go to work ready for this
though yeah we're driving in the cvs
right
in the corolla in the corolla 10 minutes
it's a 10-minute drive we're in the
corolla about minute eight
sh you know what she says to me she goes
i'm pregnant and i said you're not
pregnant she goes i've been pregnant
before i'm [ __ ] telling you i'm
pregnant she goes i just got light
headed out of nowhere i think the sperm
i think your sperm just hit my egg and i
was like no and i was like no way that's
impossible
it's like this is your brain on drugs
yeah like she was i was like like a
direct hit like a [ __ ] bullseye yeah
and she goes um she goes i'm pregnant i
was like you're not so she go so we go
get the pills she takes it i saw her
take it whatever we go and she go and
she was like listen it happens whatever
she's like i'd love to see you again
like i'm actually starting to like you
so now i'm like hold on
did she take the pill there in real time
or you let her leave with the pillow no
no she took it like she took it in real
time oh yeah she dropped it down and
yeah
why dude cause she wanted to take the
pill like you know what i mean i want
you know what i mean
so that was that was august okay
september 11 2014. i was doing a show at
side splitters in tampa shout out tampa
the owner the owner of that comedy club
i remember that night had told me i just
punched a woman in the face in the
parking lot the night before and he was
proud of that they do that yeah so i
remember i remember that's what i was
thinking that's tampa dude that's the
tampa national anthem he goes you want
to see the footage i knocked some women
out in the parking lot the other night
it was like
yeah
yeah i was like great then he goes i bet
your whole paycheck you can't make me
laugh on the saturday late someone's
like what the [ __ ] i was like you're a
dirtbag criminal
so
yeah and then he put the comedy condo he
had put me and damien lemon shout out
damien lemon the comedy condo yeah he
had put me and damien lemon at had a had
a tooth in the sink oh yeah so we had
called our manager and we got out you
know we gotta we gotta found a nice
hotel room in clearwater but in a tooth
in the sink oh yeah
[ __ ] dexter sweet yeah and there were
two of us and one of us had to sleep on
a pull-out sofa yeah so so
so
that's september 11 2014 i'm down there
i was talking i'm not sleeping i was
talking to jasmine a lot you know but
but had no plans for her to come to
tampa and she called me that morning
september 11 she goes she goes hey i was
thinking i'm gonna come out to tampa
like you know it's be cool to be in
florida i said yeah come on you know
come out you know whatever she was like
i'm gonna come out i'm gonna see if i
can make it there for you for your late
show i'm going to get a flight right now
it was like great wow i was like this is
awesome like i'm you know not thinking
anything i've been talking a little bit
yeah oh yeah no we're talking still you
know every day every other day you know
she has a family and whatever and i was
like
yeah so
finally uh she gets there and she looked
beautiful i came off stage that night
and she was like gorgeous tan amy and i
look good like i didn't i was in the
evening i'm like two four i'm 241 pounds
not back then i was about two on that
close too
you know
no but i'll sing it with you uh it just
reminds me it's like a romance song
so yeah go to a party
oh yeah i know that song yeah yeah but i
don't know any of the words after that
everyone stop and stay yeah you're
saying that like you're deaf i like it
i think it's all i got man yeah dude i'm
tone deaf and i'm literally toned down
yeah so okay so you get off stage she's
there she's there beautiful do they have
a nice green room there no it's a shame
oh you stand in the back of the bar they
don't have a green room right there's
this you can see all the tubes coming
out of those boxes that do the soda like
do the soda thing yeah
yeah and that guy was just oh my god
yeah dude it's a corolla yeah it's bad
dude and the owners back there just
beating the [ __ ] out of women yeah yeah
just like what is happening
so
so i said so i was like wow you're here
and she goes yeah and then she had lined
up three shots she was like you gotta do
shots and i was like this is [ __ ]
awesome we're gonna have you know i have
sex again tonight like great i said i
got a nice hotel room you could see the
bay you know whatever
so we go back we you know have fun with
me her and damian go out to a bob evans
we after that we got some food and then
we have some fun yeah and then we go
we we go back to my hotel room get back
to my hotel room and you know you know
she's like and is damian like hanging
around too much or he gets no damian
gets it he's like you know i'm gonna
leave you too he's always that weird guy
who's like hey nah damn come to your
room and let's play a game like this
damian's cool [ __ ] bro he knew what was
going on yeah yeah damien was like just
letting him
hold my wiener up to keep it hard
here unless you're gonna stand under it
like this yeah dude no damian knew what
was up
good guy nice guy so i hadn't even
thought of because you know the the
birth control the uh uh the the morning
after pill was like an afterthought
because it's like you know she had taken
i was like nobody's thinking anything i
wasn't thinking anything and she didn't
what happened she didn't swallow it no
she did she did
so
ah but she comes on september 11th we
we're in the hotel room that night and
she goes um
she i i i go to use the bathroom
and
she uh says when i come out she has a
pregnancy test that's positive
and she goes um
she goes this is your baby she goes
here's the thing
she goes i don't you know really want to
do this i have a son she goes i told you
in the car i was pregnant
that birth the morning after bill didn't
work she was like i told you i told you
she goes so you know you have your
career your life i think you're a nice
guy i've had a lovely time with you i
would love to even can continue to see
you she's like but i'm not going to have
another child
like this you know she's like i already
have a child to a son to deal with that
i'm not with her his dad is she being in
long island huh what did she mean like
have another child on long island
no i think she meant like have another
child with a guy who maybe doesn't want
to get married or maybe like that or
maybe she didn't mean i don't want to
have a child with a guy who lives in the
five boroughs that sounds like a human
sewer cap right maybe she said that
right that's possible right because her
ex
her son's father does sound and look a
lot like me oh he does yes she has white
children she's made that very clear
she's only going to procreate with white
men and that's just her prerogative yeah
so if you're not white you you can hook
up with her but she will not bury your
children that's her that's her words not
yeah everybody has puerto ricans yeah
she said this is like that macadamia nut
that's what she said she was like yeah
so
so she was like i want my kids to have
psoriasis so i said so i said um i said
to her i said to her you're pregnant you
know it's 100 mine she goes yes it's 100
yours
obviously and i was like um
i was like okay and then i had that
moment in my head where i was like
you know i'm 30 years old i willingly
did this i have my career you know where
you know not where i wanted to be but i
was like things seemed to move in the
right direction i had my education i
said i was irresponsible by acting in
the moment and deciding not to pull out
and do that because i was feeling
inferior to another i created all these
dumb things in my head because i'm nuts
i said no i said to her i said look i
said
i would love to have this child even
though i know i barely know you you we
don't know anybody you don't know my
family i don't know yours i said there
could be a million red flags with the
both of us i was like but i would love
to be a father to this child i was like
i don't know if you and i would work out
i don't know if you'll hate me or like
me i don't know i said but i know for a
fact like i will make this child like my
whole life like i promise you that will
happen sounds so japanese all of a
sudden yeah dude yeah well i dropped a
[ __ ] nuke in her so i said so i said
i i said
i will do that and she was like
let me think about it let me think about
it oh my god and then we woke up the
next morning this is like on joe dirt
whenever that thing happens he's [ __ ]
at the sewer system or whatever and he's
drinking [ __ ] out of a can and he's like
brandy wouldn't touch my dick you know
and they left me
we'll be right back um okay yeah so she
said so we will let me think about it we
woke up the next morning we were in
florida in tampa bay woke up the next
morning and there was a pelican on our
balcony and i was like that's a stork i
was like that's a stork even though i
knew it wasn't i was like that's a stork
yeah and because she you know she
doesn't know there's two pelicans and
storks
she was like that's a sign then that's a
massive stork
i said that's our baby right there
that's a stork
and she was like if you're gonna be a
good dad and you promise me that you'll
then we can do it wow and you did it and
we didn't that's the best and that's why
i now in retrospect even though i love
her and and you know she's always be a
part of my life i think what i was
seeing when i met her that day at place
to beach i was really seeing my child
that's what i was thinking like a a a
life thing like it because it was it was
a it was still i've never felt that way
about any woman like
stopped in my tracks like this woman is
like i felt like this woman's gonna be
like my life and that's what it turned
out like i'm forever linked to her now
we have two children it doesn't matter
what happens between us and things are
going good between us but it doesn't
matter whatever the future holds it's
like we we're linked forever
so
and then we broke up
we broke up like we were co-parenting
for years yeah and then the pandemic
happened and we got back together first
time we had sex we have now a second
daughter my seventh month old daughter
violet wow so now
so so so it's just locked in like that
and i think when you're talking about
love what i will say
is that i feel like now like i i i i
never went looking for it like at all it
kind of just organically
happened and i don't know necessarily
what being in love is or what all those
i think it's different things to
different people yeah but i know that
they'll never be
me and jasmine may not always be
together that may or may not happen but
there'll never be a woman like she will
always be priority number one in my life
no matter what you know and my daughters
of course you know my children are my
children but that's a different thing
than talk about as a grown adult woman
right she'll always be priority number
one wow like i'd kill my mom if you know
before i killed her or if i was gonna
i'd kill them both at the exact same
time yeah but i never kill my kids but i
would kill my stepson
yeah
yeah but probably not he'll probably
kill me first
yeah well i was just kidding i would
never kill any of my stepson or my
children no i don't think i could kill
anyone actually
i don't think i could kill anyone
you could
no because i'm i am very cause something
happened you could man
you know i don't understand why anyone
would spend thousands of dollars on a
new website when they don't have to
that's
that's that's crazy they'll put you in a
damn mental center if you're doing that
you're running around buying websites
you don't have to
well the team at modify
produces amazing websites
and they're producing right now the last
website you'll ever need
if you're ready to stop effing around
when it comes to your website go to
modify
m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot com slash theo
that's right they have unlimited updates
free revamps
it's 498 to start but
you'll get 50 off that starting cost and
then it's only 250 a month no
cancellation fees no hidden fees ever
they do it all they do all the designing
they did hours
theovan.com they did it all and they'd
if you got to add in something you want
to do a change of something they'll do
it you want to redo the logo they'll do
it they do it all
go to modify modifymodiphy.com
theo to get 50 off your starting costs
on the last website you'll ever need i
live in a house right now and i didn't
think i was going to be able to
because i had negative credit issues
things that had happened something
hadn't paid this this had happened
i'd never gotten this bill and that had
happened
well
i got my credit repaired
before i applied for my loan and the
dings were gone
bridge credit solutions
they are the ones that did it they are
backed with a 100 money back guarantee
for any items that cannot be removed
so you will not find that anywhere in
credit repair if they can't do it you
don't pay it that's it
you know exactly what you're paying for
at the beginning of the repair
bridge credit solutions prides itself on
lightning quick turnaround time
that's right though guarantee removal of
certain negative items in as quick as 24
hours
schedule your free credit audit in three
easy steps zoom or phone call
and get a free three bureau credit
report with 30 days of free credit
monitoring and identity theft program
when you sign up through their link
bridgecreditsolutions.com
theo that's bridge credit solutions dot
com slash theo once scheduled a bridge
credit strategist will contact you they
helped me they can help you well here's
here's here's advice that i i just
received okay i just received advice so
i have a character on my podcast on the
chrissy chaos podcast called tt jerry
yeah i know yeah so tt jerry is if you
guys listen to the chrissy chaos podcast
tt jerry is jasmine's
godfather who's transgender who's been
was in prison for 25 years was son of
sam's uh prison [ __ ] as she describes
for many years also had sex sex with uh
son of sam had sex with um
the amityville uh uh
massacre the amityville horror house you
never heard of that the answer doesn't
patrick or something no his name was
ronald defeo uh he uh yeah tt said that
he she used to he used to let uh
she would let him jerk off to her they
were right now so so you know she had a
knack for killers and so so she told me
those 25 years in prison she told me
recently on the podcast she said if you
went to prison what i would tell you if
you ever went to prison
what you needed to do is immediately say
that you're trans you would immediately
need to start taking estrogen pills i'm
not saying you have to cut your penis up
but you should take estrogen pills
because then they will move you to the
transgender part of the prison and
you're safe there because if you're
going with the general population men
they're going to rape you and kill you
probably immediately she was like so i
would start sit claim your trans and
take start taking estrogen pills
immediately so that's just a little word
of advice out there
yeah because i bite my nails
and i got to grow my hair that's what
you're saying yeah or they say that
that's good for women also biotin biotin
biotin i think it's called biotin yeah
she told me to take estrogen to to fully
start growing yeah she knows look yeah i
shouldn't say anything but she but now
that she's in our life you know she's
really helped us me and jasmine through
some of our problems we've been having
she's helped us because she's like hey
i've actually been in prison i've
actually been in solitary confinement
don't make your life a prison when you
guys are free just support each other
you have two beautiful children don't
have you guys make up you put yourselves
in these prisons she's like i was for
real federally incarcerated so don't do
that so that was a big thing but but
about the love thing is is is i think if
you don't look for it i i do believe
love
you know this is this is gay and i love
[ __ ] when my dad's asleep but what what
it is if love finds you you don't find
it i think the people that go looking
for it it's a forced thing you know what
i mean yeah yeah
and also who would be better who better
to do relationship advice than somebody
that's trans somebody that has a
relationship going on inside of their
body i was going to say that that she
sees both sides she comes out from both
sides dude why are we not using trans
people to help us
do marital advice and support because
they are a man and a woman they
nobody could sort it out at once than
the original recipe and sometimes the
best times of tt jerry is when sometimes
she goes like minotaur she goes half man
halfway sometimes she'll be wearing like
she sharpens her feet no you know i
remember once recently she was wearing
one of my sweatshirts from the denver
comedy works and nice they do that yeah
she was wearing my sweatshirt from
denver comedy works and jasmine's high
heels and my six-year-old daughter's
pants so she was
she was fully like it was crazy you know
because that's thing about dating a
puerto rican woman is you know when i'm
folding their laundry i don't know what
clothes are my six-year-old daughters
and what clothes is they're not the
whole culture
because they wear very tight clothes
yeah small clothes yeah you know and the
good thing about jeff is her mother's
beautiful so you know like long term you
know because i because my father is a
very uh my father is a very weird
looking man he's almost like he looks
like he's upside down like he's he's got
different parts like he almost looks
like he was assembled when god was drunk
you know i don't know god was doing
something i think we can see him on your
instagram yeah yeah he's a hideous
looking man tampa tony so jasmine has
brought that up like you know you're
gonna really fall apart soon you know my
dad looks like fred flintstone yeah so
but jasmine's mom is is beautiful so
yeah i recently posted him if you look
at his name is tampa tony um there you
go to the right so if you see he looks
like you know a lot of people think he's
special needs
and um you know yeah yeah he can smile
kenny yeah and he can't smile and and
you know he's wearing diabetic socks and
he was in tampa last night i was at the
tampa theater and he was telling he was
asking uh girls to look at his tampa
socks he said how's my drip oh i love
these tampa socks but yeah so that's my
father so he's not you know what i mean
he's kind of looks like he's he's
falling apart and he's got a lazy eye so
i get when jasmine's like i don't want
to be with you long term because that's
what i will turn into he gets a little
shawshank around the boots he definitely
seems like he has that cut fresh out of
prison he wears referee sneakers a lot
of people don't know how to stand when
they get out of prison yeah so that's
how my dad is
so um and but here catherine narducci
likes it she's from uh goodfellas that's
beautiful she's the wife from goodfellas
so shout out katherine it's cool man um
so so yeah dude so i think so i think i
think i will say that having a family
yeah he's good man he's got one of the
tiniest penises you've ever seen in your
life man tiniest truthfully man where
it's like it was a little bit of a thing
where i used to think my dad just was
balls like because we would take showers
you know take a shower at your dad once
in a while and and um
he really truthfully like i'm very
blessed i don't have his penis very
blessed i remember taking a shower my
dad because
that was
probably 76 or something 75 and i'll
shower 74 maybe when i shower with him i
don't know what year was your dad born
1910 1910 so did he fight in world war
ii
no or world war one did he was he a late
late edition he was born in nicaragua he
didn't have uh
he didn't have uh they were neutral
american war i think i mean they were
having
nicaraguan he's half nicaraguan so
his mother was i guess but he had people
like were eating dirt in his village and
stuff like that right 76 years old it
was pretty sad he said it was pretty sad
but people were eating dirt but um
yeah no i know dude so i think that dude
i think you know if this was about love
today i think that um i i will say this
i will say that having a family it does
make all my problems that i used to
complain about
seem very minuscule like i don't care
about like i love comedy it's my career
but i don't get all bent out of shape if
i don't get an audition
if i don't sell this many if i don't do
that i'm like yo i just go play with my
kids man right like my kids your kids
bring you back i think you have to have
something that grounds you i'm not
saying you have to have a husband and
wife and kids but you have to have
something that gets you outside of your
work like japanese people
they are so identified they are they
have japanese people have a very very
high suicide rate for people over 65
because when they retire they usually
kill themselves because they were just
identified by their job so i identify
myself as you know a father and then
like then the other stuff is comedy and
this and that but i think having the
kids it's actually a saving grace
because i don't the problems that i just
even like old relationships i just don't
care i'm like right like even i have a
friend right now he's going through
he's like agonizing over should he get a
divorce from his wife or not but they
have no children i'm like buddy do it
it'll be over in an hour for you like
you don't even have kids man like just
get out of it you're making you're
you're putting yourself in this prison
like you don't have children right if
you have children it's a lot harder if
you don't have children it's like just
move on with your life for me and jazzy
has been harder times because we're like
what were you going to walk away from
your kids like you know
my six-year-old daughter says when when
you're not here i get scared daddy so
what am i gonna i'm gonna go stay in a
ramada because i want to get some side
[ __ ] no you can't do that right you got
to go in the in the guest bathroom and
jerk off because you i'm not gonna have
my kids scared and i'm gonna be in the
ramada with a side piece would you wait
your children to sleep before you'd
masturbate for sure
um
can we what do you mean
didn't insane to talk about that no yeah
you know you never match to be in front
of your kids of course but no
yeah and why would you even say that out
loud that's kind of i mean it's they're
my kids
you know like and actually they were hit
yeah so it's like yeah it's just taking
them back to the old shop you know you
know the government getting involved in
family matters is a very new thing for
most of american history the government
could not get involved in a family
matter like if if if you killed your
wife
that was up to the family if they wanted
to if the family said hey we want to
prosecute you all right fine but the
government couldn't just step in and do
family it was family
george washington's era
you could do whatever the hell you
wanted missing your family central dude
yes central i think uh the
well once they made it illegal for you
to have a graveyard on your premises is
that truthfully illegal that's when it
started to get really really strange
yeah interesting that's very very very
interesting because
yeah dude so what do you do with your
family what's but i mean what are you
what so so so you you think why let me
ask you this why do you want to fall in
love do you think it's going to save you
is it just you're at a point in your
life you don't want to be alone i think
there's some things like there's some
things you just said it's like
i think for one people are always like
get a pet get a wife get her something
get a kid you know i almost wish a girl
would show up with a kid that i have and
i don't you know in a weird way not like
i didn't want to be there for the few
years but
um
yeah i just think i need some i just
want something different in my life so
i'm not gonna like settle for some weird
thing or you know you know come and
somebody i just met at a [ __ ] you
know some ira you
yeah but i mean but maybe that is the
way to do it i think
some of it is just about just doing it
like one of my friends i'm always like
man i think i have trouble in
relationships to my friends like you
have trouble relationships until you
do a relationship so it's like you just
have to do it and so
that's kind of where i've been i
recently i took a break from dating in
um
december okay i took a complete break
from dating and interacting with uh
females
so
that kind of helped me get at least a
little headspace because i would just i
just been kind of frenetic for years
just kind of like
one girl to the next yeah you just don't
really think of like what's important
you know you just kind of get used to
just messaging and doing this and that
and then you're just kind of
i wasn't intentional
right
so now i'm just i'm i'm starting to get
to a place where i like to be more
intentional so i just think like yeah
what would be new things in my life
something that would be new
would be being in a loving committed
relationship does that woman need to be
vaccinated
i do not care if that woman's vaccinated
okay
so she doesn't have proof for a vaccine
car she doesn't have to have the booster
no okay that's good because then that
widens the playing field oh yeah if you
say i'm only gonna have vaccinated women
it's just tough right now you know
because i think most of the women that
you want to deal with are not vaccinated
yeah i'll go non-vex you don't mean you
know because it's there it's it's it's
becoming quite clear that it's very
difficult to deal with you know a very
ultra liberal woman they're very you
want to go republican if you're looking
for love in a relationship if you're
looking for a one night of fun then i
would say you can go more liberal but if
you want i mean a woman who's going to
be by your side then i think you want to
go republican yeah is what i is what i
would recommend or at least someone who
leans right they don't have to be ultra
right wing nut job but i would say their
priority should be to the right because
it's becoming clear that you know the
people to the left is just it's a losing
battle you know well it's someone over
there is getting weird i mean whenever
you get way out on the fringe it gets
really weird but yeah either
that's one of the reasons why i got a
place in nashville during this panda it
was like it was normal there like there
was no right nobody was masking nobody's
doing like no it was normal and it's
been fine it's fine so that was like you
know rogan asked me why'd you move there
and i couldn't i mean taxes are you know
there's no state taxes and stuff in here
you know they might even move them up to
18 in california but um i know new york
and california the worst i know but then
also there's a lot of great things about
living in those places so it's like you
get it yeah you don't want to you know
but yeah i would say i would say if
you're looking for love but it was just
free there you know i was like you all
want to live in a place that was free
and it felt strange when i came to other
places and like
people now stay with them
for you man if i'm being honest with you
just like just violence
i need my friends to be honest with me
as a pretty mature guy like you know or
the most
you do is the most mature in my life and
and being a father and just being
knowing what i think just being truthful
is for me man when i look at you i think
you would you want a a right-leaning
woman who's from wyoming i think you
want a state like a wyoming or an idaho
you want someone like that you know what
you don't want someone who's in
entertainment you know you don't want
someone you know and you don't want
someone who's storming the capital i
think you'd like a nice just like like
like watch that show yellowstone and a
woman like that is what you want maybe
something maybe you could contact kevin
costner and see if there's an extra
something like that who's single and
available in montana yeah i think that
would work for you man i could see you
with that because you're and they're
tall too and wind burn a lot of them
have wind burns a lot of them
yeah and i think that you know they
would cook a lot of the stuff that you
like to eat like ferret and whatever
other you know because it's from
louisiana so you know you guys eat
griddle cake griddle they know all that
stuff ooey gooey pie whatever that crazy
[ __ ] is you know because we have to play
pretend a lot like with a lot of these
places like they're real places you know
but i think with the pandemic a little
bit of dove yeah
so you know like you just you know so so
i think that i think that um that's who
i would go with uh if i was you you know
and i think that you'll find it man
you seem like you're in a happy healthy
place when i saw you your cheeks look
good really yep you did you look good
because i saw the one one time i saw
your cheeks look sunken in like i was
almost like man does theo have aids or
something but like gaunt like horus gone
yeah but now you're good man you look
healthy you look good and your hair
looks good your hair looks like you're
using purple plus or something really
yeah your hair looks shiny man like i
know you're using conditioner i've been
feeling bad about it but not really bad
about it i'm just grateful to have some
hair right now uh yeah man i think i
have coven
what i just feel body aches dude do you
yeah but i haven't got it once a lot
though yeah yo i've been in the room
with coven like 15 times man dead ass do
you ever get it
no i got the antibodies yeah so did you
get the booster
um i'm sure i've missed
i'm sure i've missed some shots yeah
dude
yeah me too i had a fake one for a while
but then i just i had to get the juice
yeah i think it's like look
i don't know i don't i don't even want
to get in all that honestly yeah you
can't right at this point well you can't
make public statements
well i just don't
i'm just overhearing it it's like what
you know i i can't fathom they're gonna
get people to go get some other booster
are they what are you [ __ ] insane at
this point it's like you're literally
just throwing dart you're literally just
stabbing people to cvs you know like
it's getting modded
yeah no i'm waiting for the next one man
even people that believe in it don't
even believe in it not anymore dude you
know even aoc's out there with no mask
on everybody you know like nobody gives
a [ __ ] yeah dude
one of my friends used to hook up with
aoc really i had the bar she used to
work out yeah wow he said she's really
not like that he said deep down she
she's republican wow crazy right yep
i yeah i think well there's a lot of
identifying people that want to be just
a you know they want to be something and
they i think a lot of people out of fear
too their boss is a certain thing and
they feel like they have to be that
right um
but it's funny when we're talking about
2015 and even before that it's like i
don't think people ca it's so crazy how
divided people got i know i know because
you know what it is when you think that
you let when you but when you really
think that you let
a some political thing divide you from
your own family members and a lot of
it's just things you heard or you know
it's like
it's not like real [ __ ] between you and
them it's just like
pieces that you both heard on social
media and stuff and just fueling it's
kind of crazy you know my father said
this in 2008 2009 you know this is a man
with an eighth grade education but very
street smart as you could you know yeah
you know as a special needs man and he
was saying that he said in 2009
he said this this twitter thing is going
to be the worst thing that ever happened
for this country and i was like why he's
like because not everyone's supposed to
be talking
and it's come out to be true social
media is like not everyone's supposed to
have an opinion this is not this is not
what it is he's like you can't let the
whole world talk and i'm like it's
pretty true because now you get people
galvanized little sections of them and
then they do big things where it used to
be you know these people's ideas would
just they would get shot down at a you
know at a cafeteria in biloxi it
wouldn't go any further than that right
but now it's like that cafeteria biloxi
you know you can get that to thousands
millions billions of people yeah so it's
problematic but i think we're i think
we're going back in the right direction
i think i think um
i think we're going to be all right man
i think once biden dies of natural
causes it's going to be all right you
know because i think they're going to
have to push him they're going to have
to do something with him you know i
don't want him to die no but he's like
i don't know it's like watching old
yellers yeah i think i think that the
united states is like do this i don't
think i i think that the powers that be
are gonna they're gonna say you know
they might just get lee harvey oswald
back back you know it might get the
juices flowing again
oh to assassinate it would be easy just
you know it'd be because you just don't
you just uh you just don't give him his
pills that morning
it's just i don't know but also
government has become such a that's not
even our government anymore facebook is
our government yeah it's our problem is
our government like those are the things
the ruling entities the rest of this is
just bull it's like trial by twitter
it's it's people just arguing about some
[ __ ] well it's become states rights
that's why when you know you live in a
place like tennessee or florida you live
a different life than you do other
places like i've never thought i would
ever want to even consider leaving new
york but this there's a very simple
thing like in new york my six-year-old
has to wear masks in her classroom all
day and she hates it i hate it for her i
hate it for her social people i'm not
worried the breathing is like whatever
but her you can't deny like when my
child doesn't see her friends when you
see a someone's full face you get an uh
you know her brain is forming she can
see people smiling she doesn't
understand reactions it's not harming
her where if i just moved her you know a
thousand miles to the south in florida
she's living a free life like it's 2019.
so you're getting there in your career
you can do that it's making me i have to
make like an honest decision if in the
summer this summer they're like hey
we're going mass on again then i'll i
for i don't want her to live like that
i'm not anti-vaxxed or anti-science i'm
not a right-wing nut i kid around but
like seriously i'm like that's a simple
thing that's a very easy thing for me as
a parent where like i just don't want my
child wearing a mask anymore i don't
well i just i think the whole thing's
interesting how none of the so like none
of the social effects of this have come
into
any conversation there was never any big
conversation the fact that if we shut
everything down
we're going to have hundreds of
thousands of people
that are going to die from addiction
from loneliness
yeah
all the people that probably seniors
that died of heartbreak because they
couldn't see their [ __ ] family
it's like and that a lot of that stuff
is unquantifiable and i bet
i really believe that it could be more
than
the amount of people that died from
covet in america anyway 100 i really
believe it just because for me you know
it's my own thing i have six friends
that overdosed and died i turned the
pandemic completely dead gone off the
earth right right i don't have i don't
know anybody that died of covet that's
just me it's my own world
but
if they had aaa meetings that were open
and recovery houses that were open it
might not have been the same case for
some people so i don't know i agree i
might have a different chip on my
shoulder no but it's about that it's a
mental health issue like in new york i
saw the other day i saw a guy
in the middle of the day
uh it's like a homeless man and he
started uh like i saw this full he
started like uh full spray [ __ ] like
diarrhea on a brick wall right right
near penn station in new york city about
square garden like just full [ __ ] on
a brick wall yeah like it was crazy dude
like wild wild behavior like just nuts
when people are desperate when you're
spraying your something out of your body
onto a wall to like yeah get a message
across that's desperation spray [ __ ] and
a woman was walking by and i because i
was stopped i was like oh my god a woman
was walking by and she was called him
gay or something no she walked up to him
and she go she called me gay for no
reason and she goes and she walked up to
him and she goes she goes excuse me sir
put on a mask
and i was like i mean this guy's spray
[ __ ] against the wall and you're
worried about his covet status like you
know like it's just like we're outdoors
in public let them you know it's a
mental health issue like the people who
are the most afraid have
all three vaccine shots probably two
boosters they wear six masks and they're
the ones that are terrified and i'm like
it's a mental health issue it's clear
it's a mental health issue now right you
know yeah it's interesting man well it's
just
the mental health side of it is really
interesting and a lot of that hasn't
really been explored and it'll all be
looked at probably years down the road
but the thing is i think dr fauci is
like just a like cute you know what i
mean like i like seeing dr faunch i know
what his science is what it is but it's
like he's just a small italian man
like somebody's no-no you know like yeah
like he just comes out there with like a
wooden spoon and we'll you know he'll
hit covet with a new
newspaper you know like like i i like
him i guess he does have a cute ambiance
yeah man like he looks like if a
tortellini became a national health
doctor you know like i'm like i like him
man but he lost him when he threw out
that pitch at the nationals yeah he
stinks at baseball yeah which is crazy
because a lot of those italian guys who
grew up in brooklyn they play stickball
and joe dimaggio yeah dude so he's he's
he's strimski was the italian calling
you shramsky no
yeah i think your shrimpsky's polish
yeah yeah
one of my friends uh polish guy just had
a baby
wow he was a guy actually he got
circumcised at 19 years old man
showed up to school on crutches man oh
yeah and he did it for a girl that
didn't want to uncircumcise just pierce
your ears
that's what i said and then she dumped
him about two weeks later [ __ ] his
dick up man his dick was swollen like it
was it was bad dude you ever pierced
your own ears for a woman
my own ears for a woman
no i mean the craziest thing i did is i
got a woman pregnant because i felt
inferior to her ex
and i i started a full life i locked
myself into in
woman for the rest of my life
i just saw once on instagram
yeah yeah that's cool though
yeah i go for it man yeah i think you do
shooters i take swings dude
shoot man i want to be that's what i
want to be i want to be the guy that's
willing to ejaculate and somebody i just
met yep i did it man and that's why
that's why like i there's um you know
i'm proud of the fearlessness you know
yeah i'm proud of it because i'm like
i'm like you know what man like if i'm
gonna get a woman pregnant who i barely
even know just to get even with her ex
that i barely that i
flat out don't know that i've created in
my mind then yeah dude i'm gonna take a
chance on a joke i'm gonna add a show
that i probably shouldn't have added i'm
gonna make a ticket price i don't give a
[ __ ] go for a new american dude
i'm taking big swings dude i'm taking
big swings and that's semen swings and
that's what you have to do man
especially in our careers like you gotta
take big swings dude yeah i got to get
on the joe rogan show too yeah never
been on it once never once oh you'll
probably probably be right around the
corner no but you know what dude i'm
proud of you're doing great without i
was going to say i'm proud of of of the
the ticket sales and all that and people
have been coming out to see me without
any rogan appearance i'm proud of that
yeah you know so i don't know but you
think if i ever do get on him what
should i take a swing at him just to
like stand out what i mean no
that's the move or like try to or like
kill one of the security guards or
something no i don't bring his head
[Laughter]
um
but dude you're kill i mean what else is
the thing is with you man theo is is you
know i was talking to opie the other day
we used to do the opie and anthony show
or the opium gym show at the time a lot
i was talking opie the other day and we
were just talking about how man theo was
killing it and we were like um
he missed you man he would say he wants
to take a walk me and him around new
york city just to walk oh wow and i said
well i said if if theo's ever in new
york i'm sure we if he's got the time
and we'll take a walk i had so much fun
on there that's when i was really
cutting my own hair for about eight
years and i've been on there i remember
that we had that back and forth where i
said you look like eileen wernos you
said i look like a deaf guy that goes to
the gym yeah yeah it was it was good
back and forth and then carl was in the
middle of carl
dive man everybody else in there died
carl died
his name died
everyone wanted
i don't think uh vic was no i think vic
they said he died of a blood clot which
is interesting because he died of a
blood clot and this was about april i
think of 2020 where he might have been
early covered you know because they were
saying that covert was causing blood
clots or it might have just been around
vic had gotten hit by a car a few days
before and wouldn't go to the doctor and
opie was like you need to go to the
doctor dude you got hit by a car man and
he was like i ain't going to get i ain't
going a doctor so there might have been
a blood clot forming in his but i mean
got fully hit by a car that'll caught
your blood if you get hit by a [ __ ]
vehicle dude if anything's going to
clutch your blood it'll be that that's a
crazy thing man to get hit by a car
uh i remember
uh
trying to steal my mom's car one time
and like it started i was pushed i got
the bra in it but it was kind of uphill
a little and i didn't realize it would
start coming back i wasn't gonna be
strong enough and i got like sandwiched
between it and another car on my thighs
and it was just [ __ ] so much pain
dude damn dude and i had these black
bruises on my legs
for about two weeks didn't have to yell
for help and [ __ ] it was so horrible
that sucks dude i remember one time i
was driving me and my dad i was in my
dad's old mobile and nice legs all four
of his doors opened up on the verrazano
bridge going to staten island yeah you
know all four of the doors at the same
time it was wild and i didn't have a
seatbelt on i was like 11.
yeah my dad was just holding me my
sister fell out of by a mcdonald's out
of an olsonville out of a cut out of a
cutlass or something or a deltoid delta
cutlass delta88 damn dude those [ __ ]
those locks on those doors are weak weak
as [ __ ] man weak locks i miss
oldsmobiles yeah
a lot of things man
i miss a lot of things dude um
uh
what else are we talking about
no dude we're just flowing man i felt
like this is this you came at me and we
were we just started talking about love
which i could talk about it all day
because i think it's got many different
definitions dude yeah and i don't know
if all your fans will like this maybe
some of them tuned out but the ones that
stayed man congratulations because uh
you know it's a different vibe we're not
still going to talk about jokes all the
time we're talking about love
well yeah well i think a lot of people
want to hear that
oh i think i mean it's just what i've
kind of been like
not thinking about but it's like
you know
you want to see if it's out there yeah
you know i want to see if it yeah and
listen dude and maybe it's only out
there for you for a month or two or a
year and then it goes away but you know
nothing's last forever i want to get
that i think i would like to get that
marriage you want to get married see
because i had children first i don't
want to get married okay if i would have
gotten married
and they have the kids that's one thing
but because i had the kids first i don't
see to me what i think of is marriage is
this is my opinion marriage is a piece
of paper it feels archaic it feels like
something you would do like if you're
very wealthy like if you're on that show
succession then you get married because
it's power dynamics but this marriage
thing now is just a piece of paper that
some guy made up that had to be a thing
it's not real but children like that's a
type of marriage from the universe i
can't explain i'm forever locked in to
my children's mother now and that's not
that's from something that's from god
that's some powers i don't understand
yeah but the piece of paper is like
that's just whatever state you live in
there's different rules you got to pay a
guy that's how i look at it and some
people will say oh that's a [ __ ] way
of looking at your you know your you
know that that ain't cool but i'm like
that but but that's how i feel that's
heaven's eggs dude that's that's
children i would like to have i think
then some matrimony i think i would like
to then maybe just even if i co-parented
or something have like a loving
environment that brought some children
into the world i would say having
children man it's it's the most
beautiful thing uh listen it's all ego
the thing is it all stems from it all
stems from a degree of narcissism that
everything you know uh even mothers love
you know the reason why you love your
own children is because it's a piece of
you right so so that's okay to i think
to accept that um you know you can't put
yourself before your kids because you
need to you need to make sure you're
healthy and strong so you can be healthy
and strong for your children you know
what i mean like like so so when some
people are like oh my kids are
everything my kids are everything to me
they truly are but i have to be mentally
and physically happy and healthy so i
can pass it on to them so i'm always
think every decision i make i'm thinking
about that you know yeah see i like that
i think i would like to just have
something and i don't i don't want to do
it because of that but it would be nice
to have something in the world that
makes me less
self-focused yes because i think that's
the only way that it popped like that
you know i can get outside of my own
thoughts and ego is to cause i can't you
know i can't sit there and commiserate
all day about career or about something
i said five years ago or about what are
people saying about me on social media i
can't commiserate about that because my
daughter needs to eat right you know and
and i'm like this is the real important
stuff yeah even like you know on the
social medias of the world you realize
like all you have to do is like you know
when i don't know somebody you know gets
canceled or somebody gets a bad review
on a show like all you have to do is is
delete that app and then it's gone yeah
because the real world for me is my
children as long as my children think
i'm okay i don't care what anybody
thinks of me so it's a it's like a
superpower where sometimes people will
be like wow chris you say some crazy
[ __ ] sometimes on stage like you ever
get worried about being canceled i'm
like no right because i got my kids man
and if you find you take my comedy
career away i mean i'll just go be a
physical therapist i have a license like
i don't want i love doing comedy i love
this i want this to be my life yeah but
why not stretch a guy's leg out
somewhere you know what i mean i might
do both dude as a matter of fact when
the pandemic happened governor cuomo uh
of new york former governor cuomo of new
york he reinstated every healthcare
professional's license that has lapsed
as long as it didn't as long as you
didn't lose your license because you
like killed somebody but mine had just
lapsed as a matter of fact you ready for
this in the state of new york
when i got my license uh uh reinstated
in the state of new york i was told that
i was the only male physical therapist
who had had my license my physical
therapy license on on a five-year hiatus
because that's only designed for
pregnant women for women who had had
children and want to step away and raise
their kids and then come back i was the
only male
on that so there was all these people
that i was on the pregnancy base i was i
was basically the pregnancy you know
part of the you know portion of the
license i uh my license was treated like
as if i was a pregnant woman that had
bore children so i so i got my license
reinstated like that like overnight in
an email i got my full license so i
could legally you could do it i could
legally i don't remember [ __ ] because
i'm urban planner dude and my degree was
in urban planning
and uh
what would you do if you could urban you
know
if you were going to plan something out
in the urban community what would you do
with you do you plan like having a
comedy night you do neighborhood you do
shrub or you do like if a postman is
coming into the neighborhood you tell
them where to go first how to do the
best routes you do uh
zoning yeah you know
but urban planning man i don't think i'm
that's not up i don't think that's what
i'm gonna do where are we going how long
have we gone right now
how long do you would normally do
probably do another 10 or 15 minutes
yeah you want to bring dominant yeah
come on tom you want to come on in man
don de peda coming in
come join us coming in in the batter's
box baby yes sir
come on don to peta
all right here let's get your camera set
you keyed up here brother look at his
mustache ladies oh yeah it's beautiful
yeah thank you yeah he said he wouldn't
shave it man he was gonna shave it and
then he said he wouldn't do it
oh really yeah he's not gonna do it i
had a goatee and sideburns and then i
shaved it it was not a good look so i
was like let's trim it down yeah going
with different body hair is a unique
thing you know and there's only the
thing i don't love about body hair
there's only so many places you can grow
it
yeah like i i don't even like my pubic
hair like it's not like a bush it's
stringy right like it's like my pubes
almost look like you like your hair like
like long mullet like but then i'll have
bushy hair like on the back of my neck
and stuff
don told me at the atlanta punchline you
forgot your pants once no it was in
huntsville huntsville you forgot your
pants yeah this was a while ago you have
to give you his pants no no you're the
opener yeah you guys are living in a van
remember that guy yeah dude i saw that
guy not long ago he he lives in
nashville i think yeah i saw him
performing i think it was in nashville i
saw him at a comedy show nice guy
i think he quit living in the van but
that guy lived in a van for a long time
he wore his pants on stage i didn't have
a choice another man's pants how'd you
forget your pants and i hit him hard too
i think that's uh
where i was opening for funny mane no
you yeah i mean he he did like a
one-night thing and they bumped us uh so
eye-open you featured and then funny man
closed and yeah uh he shouldn't have
followed you
i think it was different times yeah
i didn't really have a following then i
just starting to catch some maybe a
little bit of opportunity you took off
right after that yeah i got to tell you
by the way you look really tan on that
screen there dude you look so good i was
working out of the um on a gym on a
rooftop yesterday nice so
it's like a full gym on a rooftop like
they opened up a gym rooftop and you can
be up there and do weights and so i was
up there thank you though so i think i
got a little bit of sun and i've been
trying to wash my skin nice all right so
your head looks and your hair look great
yeah i just want you both to know you
look terrific but my face looks a little
swollen today no no no no not on camera
i don't know it has the opposite effect
like you look fat in real life but on
camera yeah you look like if you
discovered your
skeleton it would they'd be like oh this
is like you have a prehistoric look yeah
yeah but you think women like that
though oh i think it attracts them at a
base level that somebody like me or dom
can't
replicate nice
nice um are you performing a lot down
what's going on yeah man um yeah at the
funny bones and sidesplitters i got side
splitters coming up so i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go be in that in that thing with a
tooth in there yeah the condom with it
would you stay in that condo uh
bobby jewell the man that
he he sold it so they have a new condo
now
thank goodness
yeah yeah i think there was a legend
down there oh legend man i've definitely
yeah yeah we've all been through i was
in tampa last night man i went to a
place called the tampa pizza company and
i got the fettuccine alfredo and it was
awesome and i burnt my mouth on it i
still feel the effects of that right
that's good yeah yeah but it was great
dude i did the tampa theater you ever do
the tampa theater
gorgeous place man haunted but it was
gorgeous i'm at st petersburg i'm gonna
say petersburg in a couple of weeks down
there yeah st petersburg beautiful man
and we're doing one out at the improv
actually too
best way to do it we got a night off
yeah so best way to do it man i'm going
to sign with your i signed with your
agent oh yeah well it's a week yeah
because
imagine i didn't
and my current agency is like what
they hear this uh i might get nervous
man no look i think look good at least
i'm just grateful that we're able to go
places and do shows seriously that's
been the tough thing about living in
nashville is that there's not a place to
perform but you can't do it it's not the
same it's not the same as having workout
rooms where you can yeah it's a
headliner club like they're not you
can't just pop in like you can at the
comedy store or the comedy cellar well
you can but it's like it's like a lot of
you know people that go to a lot of
shows so you're seeing a lot of the same
people yeah which is fine it's great
it's just not
it's not where i can go and do three
sets like
like this week
um i probably did
uh or last week i probably did like
12 sets you know in l.a yeah which for
me it's like that's like a time where i
can learn like i feel like by the 11th
show it's like i'm cooking with guests
like i'm not i have no fear that anybody
in the joint is gonna are you back here
now do any better than me
um
no uh no but i'm gonna be have to spend
more time here because i gotta do more
practicing good right but your permanent
residence is not here my partner
residents is not here no nashville i'm a
legal resident of tennessee wow so you
don't so you so you tennessee doesn't
have income tax either right there's no
state no state texas yeah right oh so
you're good man well one of the
blessings too is just that if you go
touring out of there they have all the
tour buses and stuff so that's really
nice is just to be able to like yeah go
do a string based out of there it's like
yeah you can't find a wife in nashville
man i probably can there's some good
there's some nice women there dude i
think so find your girl with a piece of
camo what about puerto rico
dude puerto ricans are good wives dude
and good mothers no
oh i would like something from another
country yeah what about nickel rock one
go back to your roots i wouldn't but i
got to get down there that's the thing
it's like do i you got to get down there
you know you got a plan hey you got to
be there for a couple weeks you can't
stop you know you can't four you know
hurry in a week
but i wouldn't mind i'm open to it i'm
gonna start asking god hey god
i am willing
to meet someone are you dating mostly
white women
i'm dating women that are
some of them a good amount of them are
white women right
but i am not sentenced to that i'm okay
to any type of woman
right an embodied woman i have dm'd with
women that are
all types of women you got to find a
woman that doesn't know you know that's
harder and harder though man just
watching amish maybe yeah trying or go
to china or mercenary what is it called
immerse the
yeah because they can't have they can't
have electronics uh or hasidic jewish
woman that'd be a nice call for you too
sids baby go hard
jewish baby
yeah we'll see i mean i'm open to i'm
open to anything so you got a lady right
now uh no no no uh recently no but it's
good dude you're gonna find love though
you got a good heart yeah i've always
said inside about both of you
very genuine i'm not being well he's
already got love this guy's doing fine
this guy yeah i got a lot of cholesterol
man yeah in my heart i definitely am
going to go home and probably have more
popcorn like i usually do and porn's not
terrible for you though not terrible but
it's not a family you know right it's
not a right you know right i get it man
it's not that so i'm not like lamenting
it it's just like i'm just getting to
the point where it's like okay i'm
feeling like this is a possibility
what are you are you 40 yet i'm 40 yeah
yeah so if you're 40 yeah that that's
one that you know you're the male's
biological clock starts kicking in yeah
but i think you can do it man especially
because you look like um you look like
matt damon from the last duel
yeah a lot of people have been tagging
yeah so so i think like he had a wife
you know and it didn't work out really
she came with land though she came with
lance huh yeah one of them acre babes
homie yeah
i like it man you look it's like an
andre augusty look yeah from when the
nine when he was winning though you know
what i mean dude you're gonna you're
gonna find love thanks 100 percent yeah
i think you wouldn't do that but here's
the thing that that benefits you is
committing to the love when i get in
some love you just gotta can you accept
love
i don't know somebody
that sounded like a vote
of unconfidence no dude i'm with you bro
really yeah it didn't sound like celtius
live fit
celsius live [ __ ] it did not sound like
you're into it yeah no dude you believe
in me it's just it's deep dude
you know i delta food did you yeah oh if
you eat it at high altitudes bro that's
all gas
yeah that's all gas yeah dude the fact
that they even feed people at that
altitude is insane it's insane it's
japanese it's gotta it's like a lithium
battery yeah it's gonna explode this
thing is a game show yeah it's such a
[ __ ] game show man yeah man i think i
think love is um
i don't know how it's gonna happen for
you or who it's gonna happen with it
might not not even be a female but it's
it's happening you know i want a female
you want that but that might not be what
the universe wants for you you
i'm not living with some sexual man bro
dude it's it's one of those things where
like i said man love finds you you don't
find love and if it's a man or an animal
or
you know well i wouldn't mind getting a
pup or getting something like that to
start off the
the commitment you know and so that's
what i'm thinking of but i don't know
what kind of animal i would get that i
would then
you know want to saunter around with to
have to take around a lot because it's
not all about sex either that's the
other
way it says sale yeah yeah yeah i'm
willing to do sex but that's also like
yeah as you get older it's not it's just
like
somebody awesome to be around yeah it's
weird how unimportant that comes yeah i
don't i you know it's yeah i don't care
about it as much i mean you know because
it's like it's kind of like you've done
it enough where it's like i i you know
when you masturbate it's like that's the
best you know that it is because it's
all you but so i don't need to have sex
anymore and we burned it out as a
society we burned sex used to be that it
was like that secret thing and how are
they gonna do it and you gotta sneak you
gotta somebody's gotta draw a picture
how you do it you know when you're like
you know you don't even know what's
going on somebody's behind you pushing
you into the woman like dude it used to
be totally different and now it's just
like everywhere people there's ejaculate
everywhere there's advertisements to to
to uh
get more ejaculate in your body it's
just like what's it's all it's just we
burned it out man
yeah in the civil war they used to have
um one of the generals general hooker
that's where the term hooker comes from
is he would have prostitutes follow him
and even more so everybody wanted to be
in his platoon and they would fight
harder for him because they had uh an
artist that they would protect at all
costs that would draw women that they
would meet on the road and that was like
the point and they would jerk off to
that point
that's crazy beautiful and sex is like
is is all in it's all intertwined like
in history like the french when in world
war ii when the french were getting
invaded by the germans yeah the french
they let them have sex with women and
prostitutes and a lot of them were
fighting with venereal diseases where
hitler and the germans said you are not
if you have if we catch you having sex
with a woman you're gonna get shot on
the spot so the nazis didn't have stds
that was one of their biggest
superpowers just math where a lot yeah
they and they had panzer chuck a lot
which was crystal meth but that's what
it was called panzer chocolat imagine
doing meth and not being able to have
any sex yeah dude it's crazy
so but but but that's a big thing is is
you know sex is intertwined with with
even our history but if you remove it if
you can remove the urge for sex then you
remove almost you remove 99 of your
problems right truthfully you do you
know it's all sex everything we're doing
subconsciously is for sex yeah that's
what it is it may not and you know
sometimes it's right on the open
sometimes it's not but if you can just
say to him it's difficult it's almost
impossible to do but if you could do it
that's what monks do when they meditate
when they're sitting there meditating
for 20 hours a day they're not getting
to a deeper place
they're basically just humming till they
ejaculate that's what it is they're just
basically not having sex and thinking
about sex yeah you remove it that's what
eunuchs that's why eunuchs were so
powerful because you had them you know
the the thought was you had the
aggression and the brain of a man but
you you weren't you weren't distracted
by sex that's why they cut your nuts off
they could think clearly
yeah that's what gets clear that the
eunuchs would run the ancient priests
like right after you come they will run
that exactly dude they're forever the
eunuch had forever just ejaculated and
we've gotten in that place of society
where sex isn't even that big of a deal
it's just like it used to be that big of
a deal you needed 15 children you needed
the land don't need any of it anymore
and also sexting in porn like you can
just you can you can sex with the uh the
opposite sex and and fulfill your needs
you don't have to put
the in certain them anymore and they
don't have to jump on you you don't have
to well that's one nice thing about
taking a break from dating it had me a
little bit of there was a little bit of
a reset from like just that
the pattern it's nice of like one you
know like feeling like you have to did
you find did you find more discipline in
that or like more with yourself like
more structured
yeah i found like there was things that
i liked to do that i just even forgotten
about it's great right you know yeah
dude i mean if you can just if you can
if you we don't realize how distracted
we are today even you know sometimes
i'll be at home with my children all day
but i'll be on the phone scrolling or
saying i gotta work i gotta think of it
and i realize i haven't looked at my
daughter's face in 10 hours and it's
like you know so now i try to just put
my phone away yeah if i can you know
unless there's a something important but
then just put it on now i'm like i used
to go for a long time you say i hate
talking on the phone just text me but
now it's the it's come full circle for
me and i'm like i rather you call me me
too because then i can just get off the
phone with you and i don't have to text
and be because if i start texting you
and i get sucked in but if i'm on the
phone i know i hang it up and i put it
down but if you're texting me i'm
texting you and then i don't text i'm
looking at instagram looking at the news
i'm looking at the same [ __ ] over
and over and over again and siri has a
lisp in her ears dude i i've never met
an incapable woman as siri or man you
know whatever
i think she's persian i don't even know
what she is but i've never met anybody
that doesn't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about yeah she doesn't know at
all
she's chinese but when you do the voice
she comes from china we know when you do
the voice recognition thing when you
voice to text
unbelievable yeah you might as well eat
your own ass outside dude
yeah man
um great to have you guys thanks for
coming in um which is where's the tour
at man tell me about it so baby listen
february 11th i'm at the warner theater
in washington dc february 12th at the
tabernacle in atlanta and then we got
march 4th and 5th in cleveland at the
agora theater and detroit at royal oak
uh uh and that was
mr don the pedal will be there we got
the chrissy chaos podcast thursdays 11
am eastern time hey babe with san
volcano um chrissy chaos tuesdays 11 am
eastern time hey babe thursdays 11 a.m
eastern time christy comedy.com for all
my tickets we're on a theater tour going
all the way to the end of april and i
appreciate you having me man and i hope
that uh i hope that we find love dude
and even if it's with this transgender
it doesn't have to be a a biological
woman is what i'm saying i think if you
do that then you're closing yourself off
and they don't have to be vaccinated
i am not taking allah i am hope i i
appreciate your hope for me and some of
it i don't okay
i would like a woman and i am open to
anybody the universe brings me i am open
to love the universe gonna bring you a
woman just for a couple of weeks see
open it up to more than that and see
what happens if i'm if i'm gay i would
be shocked if i am gay yeah
yeah but
if i met a man one day and i was like
jesus christ i love this man
i don't know i don't think i would be
gay for him
but
you just can't get past some certain
things i get it no i want a wife is what
i'm saying yeah
so that's even as much as i can even
think about it you know i think i don't
mind being around somebody driving
somewhere with a guy if we're going to a
re like we're all going somewhere people
are going somewhere yes i'll ride with
this guy this is my friend i'll go
somewhere with him i'll talk to guys
like this
i don't want anything really beyond that
in my life but if you could use guys
to help with women like i'm saying don't
just discount us like for example i've
said this many times i fall in love with
men i have sex with women right like
we've had a stimulating conversation oh
and i'm falling in love with you guys
but i'm going to want to go home and
have sex with a woman right so if that's
gay that's gay you know what i mean i'm
not maybe your brain gay but body
straight
there you go yeah i'm brain gay
brain gay maybe that'd be the title of
this episode dude brain gaze brain game
body style i love it dom where are you
going to be at uh where coming up i got
the dates in march with him i'm going to
beat side splitters in early june like
three through six and uh dude i'm just
in town working a ton just you know so
that's it
where are you gonna be where are you
gonna be where am i gonna be let me see
i am
[Music]
at um
you gotta be some well you're going to
be in um
i'm in jacksonville
on february 2nd i'm at st petersburg on
february 3rd
um
[Music]
on february 4th
i'm in tampa
or saint yeah saint petersburg uh in
orlando february 5th
nice action i'm in rockford illinois
february 25th and chicago illinois
february 26th
it's going to be good dude yeah and uh
the wheelchair in los angeles may 7th
some
fun dates so
um
yeah grateful grateful you guys came in
man thanks for coming in and spending
time today man i love it dude yeah i'm
excited about y'all getting out there
and making people laugh man y'all bring
me a lot of joy so thanks man thank you
brother thank you
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
but when i reach that ground i'll share
this piece of mind i found i can feel it
in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
[Music]
now